let's get more now on that un warning
that the violence between israel and the
palestinians could escalate
into full-blown war if the international
community
can't find a way to calm the situation
with residents in towns and cities
on both sides now living in increasing
fear
i'm joined now by jordana grego who
lives in tel aviv
in israel jodhana thanks very much for
talking to us this afternoon just
describe for us what it is
like to be living there right now good
afternoon sarah
it's uh it's very scary it's very tense
tel aviv is a very
uh cosmopolitan crazy fun town and in
the last uh
24 hours he basically came to a
standstill um
we had a very rough night the siren
started around
8 00 p.m last night i was at home with
my three children
my husband was not home so it was all
very stressful to
wake my daughters up and go to the bomb
shelters and help
our neighbors where old one just had a
baby
it was uh extremely scary we heard
booms and explosions we weren't sure if
missiles were falling or if it was the
iron dome intercepting the rockets
um and then we had more uh sirens around
2 30 a.m uh and then again at
three uh and it's very scary
so on all of those occasions with the
sirens you then went down to the bomb
shelter
yes you have to you have uh 90 seconds
in tel aviv
uh when closer to gaza you have really
just about a bunch of seconds to run to
the bomb shelters but
yeah you have about a minute to gather
your children
and run to the bomb shelter and then uh
you just wait and you hear
explosions and um and you just don't
know
like you check your phone and you just
wait to hear some news um
and the iron dome is doing a great job
he's intercepting the missiles but
with this amount of uh of rockets being
fired it's a barrage
uh they're not intercepting all of them
so
we're seeing a lot of casualties how
does this feel in comparison to to
previous tensions er
we don't know like really uh we you know
obviously we live in the middle east and
it's a
very explosive areas but there's always
tensions uh
on and off with uh hamas um
we sort of didn't expect since the
violence started uh
two days ago we weren't sure if it was
gonna reach tel aviv
um and we definitely didn't expect this
amount of uh
of rockets being fired towards the
center of the country
it was something unheard of we haven't
had this kind of
numbers of rockets being fired uh to
central israel in i think never so
um it's uh it's very very stressful very
worrying
uh schools have been closed uh again tel
aviv is basically on a standstill
we've just been home all day with the
children and
it's very worrying we've heard in the
last hour
hamas confirming that it's gaza city
commander has been killed
in an airstrike how concerned are you
about retaliations
uh i'm concerned
i'm not sure you know whatever strategy
the government is taking i hope it's uh
for the best
honestly escalation on either side is uh
is worrying
um it just has to stop uh
for forever not just for just round it
just feels like
the situation escalates and then things
get back to normal
and then they
and then they escalate again and um
it's um it's never ending really yeah
you you say it just has to stop the
international community
saying both sides need to step back and
yet we hear from benjamin netanyahu
vowing to
intensify attacks
look i'm sure the government knows uh
best
how to defend its citizen i'm uh
there is so much we don't know or what's
going on we don't know what kind of
arsenal hamas has been storing um
i i to be honest with you my opinion is
very
uh limited to what i hear from the news
um i just hope again uh that one day
eventually things will come down and
we'll be able to
to live in peace with our neighbors i
just don't know what it has to take
what i can see is that it's a shame that
uh in gaza for the last
20 years has been no occupation and yet
uh what we've seen is that much of the
budget has been allocated in uh buying
uh
weapons building tunnels rather than
hospitals and schools and
shelters for their population so
something also has to change within the
palestinian society and
their narrative and their goals if we
want to live together in peace if not
it's just going to continue like this
forever
at jordana the scenes at the al-aqsa
mosque this week
israeli police storming the mosque and
then pictures that we have seen
of israeli police preventing palestinian
red cross medics from
from getting into the wounded
yes it's uh we also have our uh
share of uh responsibility ever
things get hot not just hot but it's
something that we see
um an increase of uh confrontations
between the arab israelis and uh
and the police uh i definitely think
that
the whole thing could be managed better
i don't wish
i was a politician these days and had to
take decisions uh that affects so many
people
but definitely i mean you know it takes
two to tango
uh i believe i thank my country and my
government for offending me
i i just wish things were different
giordano grego thank you very much
indeed for talking to us and we wish you
all the best stay safe
thank you bye bye bye